hello good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever your hell you are in
the world and here is it very surprised
very last minute live with
um or Sunstar side track my instant's
lagging like crazy I apologize
um
it's a bit better now we're live I don't
know why let's be honest no then it
slows right down again and then if I do
that in the second I'll speed up
um my kids are about to leave the house
so they'll go off their games and it'll
speed up it'll be fine but anyway
um we have a very interesting
conversation to have because I've
managed to get a little bit more
information about some of the pitch
meetings that were done
um last summer thanks to one of my
sources at MGM and I guarantee you
Matthew at least one of these pitches is
going to make you very very angry
so I can probably guess who pitched it
let's get into it but first of all just
very quickly we'll do the intro
[Music]
so
we know about um penguin in a park and
we know the Bad Robot pitched we haven't
up till now been able to tell you what
bad robot's second Pitch involved that's
the bit that's going to make you angry
and we'll leave that for a little minute
so we'll tease you oh come on speed up I
keep thinking if I like do something
maybe it'll like get the internet to
work faster but it doesn't
um just quickly say hello to every track
gate higher popcorn power uh marvelous
Spiderman Multiverse we can only hope
track gets anything Jordan 80 you're
with us uh who'd announced I see Sarah
hi
um blah blah blah I am how you diddling
so
um we'll try and we'll try and chat to
you guys as much as we can gotta tell
you I moved to a new house I used to
have no problems with my internet I
moved to a new house and it's useless
and but and as long as you can hear me
we'll be fine so one of the first things
we've never really spoken about before
is Eric Kripke
so um I've heard Jenny Steven mention
this a couple of times that um the boys
the guys behind the boys did pitch
um but we never really knew what they
pitched and we never really knew who it
was because there's about 10 different
production companies buying the boys so
it's um saying I'm really pretty when
I'm in slow motion I'm realizing
um but Eric Kripke Enterprises was
actually one of the creators along with
Seth Rogen that actually sort of like
developed the original boy's idea
and he we are finding out now that he
did actually
pitch for um a TV series so hey Adam how
you doing sir David we've been talking
about you today
we also did Supernatural he created the
supernatural yeah
so he for me actually is one of those
people a bit like Mark Fergus that I
don't have a major problem with him
getting involved in this I actually
think it would be really really
interesting if he did
um
I just I just think
I just think it would be
he's got the right pedigree
does that make sense
um and he's developed projects like this
before
um hey Andrew
um uh it was very last minute us going
live today so
um
and then maybe that's why but you were
this name so hey and David thank you
very much evening sir
um I can't really
dude you have me tripping balls
and we'll get to it though anyway so
I actually think our [__] key is a
really interesting one
but apparently he very much followed
Amazon's
um brief for this so Amazon basically
got penguin in a Parker Last Summer
to do a
um Bible for the project so a production
Bible so it basically tells you the
story of um of um Stargate the important
bits you can't mess with as Canon and
maybe some areas that you could and
we've always said this might be a bit of
a hybrid
reboot Wiki Corner don't we that they'll
be allowed to change some things
and because of the Gap I think that's
going to be quite important a Creator is
going to have to do that or there's just
certain things that just don't make
sense otherwise
um
so
so yeah he he's his his pitch was
apparently very a bit like penguin in a
Parkers but obviously he created the
production Bible so you can expect
penguana Parker's pitch to be
um pretty much on point
the reason why I'm saying that I'm
bringing that up is because
none of the others were
none of the others seemed to they seemed
to read what Amazon told them to put
when they just went nah and did
something completely different so
um
But Eric Kripke and penguin and Parker
very much did I can't say it's so
distracting that I'm going in slow
motion I'm just gonna have a drink now
see if the drink appears in my hand
while we're talking
uh they're leaving now there you go and
then I speed up for a second and then
anyway so
I think those two we can put you on side
because we've we've talked a lot about
penguin and Parker's pitch even though
we don't exactly know what they were
talking about we know they were bringing
in certain
um
I was told basically think of it like an
sg1 Revival so it would be very much
around that formula of a show a movie
um I've got some news about the script
that he created but that's going to be
for another video so Eric Kripke
you happy to move on from that we think
that's probably about right
yeah
okay
right
the one company we've not heard of
pitching before and this was a complete
surprise to me
is Heyday films
now apparently they have also pitched
um
what what do you know about payday films
come out before we
also
not a lot other than what you told me at
the beginning
um
they did the Harry Potters
yeah so they did all the Harry Potter
movies
um they did Gravity they've just done
Barbie
yeah
they did yes man
um Wonka
so you know they've done some good films
they've done some TV as well but I I've
not really seen any of it so there's
nothing that jumped out at me anyway
um so like I said this is a British
company it's it's led by a guy called
David Heyman who used to work for
original pictures did a couple other
things he's quite a big thing as well
um
if you look at the Harry Potter work
you know some of the work they did there
is is interesting
um you know the way they developed that
from a script you could say the
similarities what they're gonna have to
do if you pretend
or the original Stargate series I like
the books and they've got to develop
something based on that they did quite a
good job with Harry Potter
about it I think you did a really good
job I mean there are certain parts of
the books that they didn't include but
that's always going to happen when
you're adapting the
a book to a film or a TV show
anything where you're doing a different
medium yeah is is different because it
requires
um tell you what I'm gonna do just give
me one second I'm just going to turn my
Wi-Fi but it means I'm gonna now I'll
tell you what I'm gonna drop out for one
second I'm gonna come back in again all
right because it's irritated me so one
second okay so you just Talk Amongst
yourselves
Let's Talk Amongst ourselves hello
everyone
this always happens when uh we're on
Jace no J um Harris's stream
his internet will go and then I'm left
here
so hi
go and get into Potter I guess I'm too
old
see Harry Potter for me was my childhood
I grew up reading the books and then
are you see if it helps yeah I regret
reading the book and then the movies
come out
um
um as soon as the movies come out I
think I kind of stopped reading the
books
the last one
yeah I saw the first film loved it so
much I then read all the books in about
a week
um but I I used to literally as soon as
they came out the books I would be first
in line not first in line but I would go
there on the day
and buy the books
yeah
even if I didn't read them I just wanted
them yeah let's just talk about this
very quickly what's a better idea this
or sdu animated
I don't have a problem with an SGU
animated movie
I I don't but people are getting really
angry about this idea about doing
animated movies around Stargate
what would you rather let me ask you a
question and let's get into the
you know Andrew Chandler no excuse for
bad internet there's like computers I've
got kids playing the pig in
um their computer games and they've gone
now though and it's still really slow
um
what would be worse an SGU animated
conclusion movie or no conclusion at all
not having a conclusion for me I would
much rather have a conclusion in some
form whether it's an animated movie
whether it's a comic book whether it's
short like
Novella kind of thing
like
I want a conclusion I don't care how we
get it
[Music]
um
and I think I think it animated I don't
know any movie could do quite well
because you look at the likes of like
Spider-Man into the spider-verse
yes it's it's it's a it's a like a
property that's already done well in
animated form
but the most popular form well not most
popular the most successful like
commercially would be the movies which
are all live action but even taking that
into account into the spider-verse is
like
just as commercial is successful
right
yeah I know Jordan didn't say that I
want a conclusion in live action so
would I I argued in my video when I was
talking about this sister like do not
want anything animated that they could
do
in live action is it gonna do it if if
that's an option do it in live action
um but the way I would say is it's just
it's more Stargate
yeah
so why not you know it's just like but
um I I wouldn't love it at the end of
the day
I don't mind animation
I'm looking forward to the B5 animation
but that's not possible to do in in live
action it's just not possible so they've
done an animated movie and I must say
that's great but I won't enjoy it as
much as live action movie or live action
I just want because it's a cartoon but
I I I'm still looking forward to it and
I'd still rather have it than not have
anything
yeah you know so that's just me I think
when you think about
um cartoons and Stargate the first thing
you need to think of is Target infinity
and it's
really a fair comparison to make because
Target Infinity was made for kids and it
was very
it wasn't designed for us basically it
was designed for a younger audience to
get interested in Stargate and that's
why we hate it and think it was a lot of
the crap because it was for us it wasn't
it wasn't for us yeah
this is like a Star Trek Prodigy it's
just been canceled and I really like
Star Trek Prodigy I know you're not a
big Trekkie but I really like Star Trek
Prodigy
um it's like watching a dubbed movie
Chinese films I'm so sorry guys it's
really annoying it's annoying me it's
like he's distracting me as well pain
yes hopefully it'll come back with me
um but um Prodigy was basically a Star
Trek cartoon made for kids putting the
Cartoon Network
um but then all the references were to
do with like Star Trek Voyager so only
40 year olds understood any of the
references
and weirdly no one watched it
um and I'm just like yeah that's exactly
what we expected why did you think
anybody would watch this TV show so yeah
they've got if they're going to do it
they've got to pitch it
at the right level and everything you
know
um I'm just gonna switch who I where I
get the internet from just a second
hopefully that one maybe I've got an
extension
we'll see
um so nope it worse instantly oh
it was fine until you joined
it's my fault
[Laughter]
but anyway you can hear me
um
so if we get back to the
um pictures and so what Heyday pitched
they immediately came in and pitched
initially apparently in August they
pitched the TV series
um and then that was they had some
really positive feedback but they
immediately came back in a pitched and
pitched a movie
um apparently
that was going to be around
um they actually pitched a hard reboot
when they pitched the TV series
um and then they came back and they
basically pitched
um
they want again they wanted Kurt Russell
to come back that was one of their
things so they they picture but
apparently the feedback the second time
was with Amazon saying look it's too
close to a hard reboot this is going to
upset people
um it's even though you've listened to
the brief and you've sort of said it's
not hard to reboot it is
um and
that was you know
a a difficulty form I'm just gonna not
look at my screen and then I won't be to
scratch my
um
I don't know loads about the storyline
that hey they were bringing in other
than to say
um they were going to bring back a bad
villain in the gold world that was gonna
make a return and they were gonna be
trying to seek revenge on the Towery for
basically wiping them out and destroying
the system Lords and so it was all about
and it was going to be more of a
um almost like a political Intrigue
because you know like the gold order on
Earth and they wanted to do something
that was real and gritty
um no no spaceships no all that sort of
thing and it was going to feel more like
like I said more like a political
Espionage movie almost rather than
sci-fi movie so
I mean what do you think about that as a
basic premise it's different
it is it's different I mean I've said it
before there's there are certain gold
out there that could potentially come
back
to seek revenge on Atari I mean even if
it's not a major system Lord that we've
seen before like obviously ball can't
come back because all of his clones were
killed a professor can't come back but
Anubis could come back but even if it's
not even if it's not one of them
we didn't wipe out the Garwood as a
species we didn't commit genocide
so
they could very easily rise to power
again or at least attempt to rise to
power again
so yeah it's an interesting premise
I and it's I think it's a
the go award when you think of Stargate
the main villain you're going to think
of is the gold yes there were
obviously other villains in Stargate but
when you look back at it
they were the villains that were the
most
prominent
so if you're learning a reboot they
probably make the most sense and I think
going back and touching base with the
original Stargate movie series whatever
as well it's not a terrible idea
um when we heard about bad robots first
pitch and we'll talk about their second
picture all truly piss you off in a
minute
um
the first pitch have ra coming back
um and they would and apparently I've
spoken some of this Sin Sin a lot of I
think they're sort of like do we explain
how our comes back and the answer is no
and he just does
um and I'm like that's that's been done
in films before that a villain just
comes back we don't know how they just
do and I'm just like is that serious
we're seriously doing like Michael Myers
version of Stargate now but that you
know a villain just comes back and
they're just like how did you survive
and I'm like yeah I don't worry about it
you just did he took a nuclear weapon to
the face and he's fine yeah he's fine
um
I mean it's a theory that Ra was an
Asgard is true
then I mean
put it put him go back into a clone body
I guess but like that was never
established in Canon it's always been a
fan Theory
and I honestly I don't want that to be
real
yeah exactly
um the Asgard thing I get and they could
also I don't know I suppose otherwise
maybe he had they're saying he's had a
personal Shield I know we see him sort
of getting vaporized don't we but maybe
we're saying that he had a shield or
something and he survived but however
um Mark makes a point Palpatine came
back
so why not he didn't look very well when
he came back to be fair he looked a bit
poorly yeah
Palpatine returning was also very stupid
so yeah
um
I I
I'm almost I'm into Minds about this I
think this idea of doing sort of like a
political Intrigue type thing where it's
I think it's an original idea I don't I
can't think
I can think of Stargate episodes that
sort of went along these lines as well
so it could sort of like run along very
classical it was probably
yeah the ball storyline where he was on
Earth posing as that businessman it
sounds similar to that and that was
brilliant yeah so Aaron's joined us so
let's let's get Aaron in and to join the
conversation hello
I'm on my phone but I'm not at work this
time so everything will be steady no
weirdness brilliant and I've got a
crappy email internet today now so I
can't complain
um but how uh how much of have you heard
about what we've been doing nothing I
was out running errands and then I saw
the message and I'm like crap so if you
could TL the art for me real quick
that'd be great well we've just been
talking about the um pictures that um
were done uh last year regarding
Stargate okay and we're up to Heyday
films Heyday films pitch but they
pitched this idea that they were going
to do this political Intrigue type of
thing where a gold was
um trying to take revenge upon the
Towery but it said it was going to be
feel much more like a spy thing a spy
movie putting movie Very gritty very
down to earth no spaceships no big
sci-fi Concepts I think
and we're just saying happiness the one
thing I quite like about this idea
is that
that the fact that 15 years have gone by
and a lot of the problems that we've
talked about in the how do you how do
you set this movie and where where are
we are with the technology and all that
sort of thing kind of is irrelevant you
don't have to worry about it too much
because you can set this in quite a
small you know it can be set in the
bowels of government sort of thing
um so they can sort of like sidestep
some of the my landmines that maybe
other projects have got to figure out a
clever way of dealing with
um
so yeah you have a problem with that
though is that if they they do go down
that route and they just don't
acknowledge them
whoever then
follows has to then deal with that and
it makes it probably a little bit more
difficult for them yeah
um Joe my kids have actually left and
it's still a problem I don't know what's
going on
um so yeah I'm gonna give them a tener
each and tell them to get out
they love their XBox more than they love
me
so
um
yeah I don't know so just do a
continuation just Marshall thanks so
much for the contribution so just do a
continuation series and bring in a new
Sgt when all guards sent them off best
droop to appease everyone that is
basically what the
um penguin in a Parker pitch was
that's basically it
so except a few of the stars from sg1
we're going to stick around
you know leader of the new SGC program
political uh you know a civilian lead or
something it's the same thing but what
do you think about the general idea
um I'm a big I've always been a big
political entry guy like mystery cloak
and daggery kind of thing so I do
definitely find that intriguing
um
I mean
I just watched the like secret Invasion
just premiered this week and I'm I'm
just like in one second I'm gonna
restart and come back okay so you guys
talk about that premise idea and I'll be
back in a second I got you mate I got
you man
um
but uh so you know and that I thought
that one started up pretty well you know
they set up all the nice cloak and
daggery stuff and that so I don't I
wouldn't have a problem with Stargate
doing something like that
um I don't know that they should
completely eliminate all the Sci-Fi
stuff from it there there's there
there's ways they could easily work
you know a couple spaceships and a
couple you know gun battles and whatnot
into an intriguing show
um I mean Intrigue shows by definition
generally have at least a few action
scenes in them anyway all you know more
often than not they are hand to hand
but you know I mean look at the borns
obviously that was Bourne movies
obviously that was grounded but they had
hella car chases there's no reason why
you couldn't expand that in a Sci-Fi
show to like
even an actress yeah even if it's an
atmospheric chase you could still have
like the x-23 or whatever the most
recent version of that is
um battling like say uh you know a a
what's a wow brain fart
um
you could have our version of the death
glider having an atmospheric dog fight
with the new gold and whoever you know
the new villains
original style death glider or whatever
so I think you could I think you could
ease
SG what yeah kind of see West Wing I
mean kind I would say probably something
more akin to SG born Identity or
something like that it sounds something
that proposal at least to me sounds
uh more like something along those lines
rather than more of a West wingy thing
but
um
yeah I I like the idea I just don't
think they need to completely exclude
sci-fi aspects I think those I don't
think that would be too hard to work
that in you know there's going to have
to be elements of it because the end of
the day there's a you there's an alien
yeah other than that other than that you
just get Andor which is a cool show but
nothing to do with Star Wars really
other than the fact that they mentioned
the rebellion and the empire
yeah yeah no true do you want to talk
about the pitch that's going to make you
angry and the the really the title of
the movie of the episode so today I've
been triggered all week so why not
go on then go on So Bad Robot did a
pitch like we mentioned earlier where
they were going to do
um they wanted to bring ra back and they
did a pitch where it was going to be
Kurt Russell and James Spader in the
original part oh I remember this yeah
Amazon basically told them very early on
that is too much like a hard reboot
that's not what we want you need to come
back with something else
uh the problem is they then came back
and they said we've solved the problem
it's not a hard reboot Multiverse of
Madness and
um so they basically said why don't we
get
O'Neill with one L and O'Neill with two
L's
into the episode so they were genuinely
pitching to try to get Kurt Russell and
Jack O'Neal the idea of the basic
premise was that a go award
that was had lost
um and that we had defeated here I was
using Asgard or so ancients technology
to go into a new universe
and where the goal doesn't didn't exist
somehow
our Jack and Kurt Russell's Jack was
then going to go and meet a third Jack
in this new universe and the idea was
that they we were going to travel there
to stop the goal award from basically
invading a universe that didn't have
um gold in it now this was going to be
very much along the lines
of what we've seen in Stargate and Canon
episodes and that was their argument
people can't get upset about this we've
already done it
yeah that's the problem you've already
done it so but it's not a good premise
for a movie
don't do it again
I mean
I'm sorry Continuum was literally that
Ball created an alternate reality an
alternate timeline it was more time
traveled in alternate reality but it
created an alternate reality
yeah if if you then like and that was
the last movie we got
what was archive three for the last one
we got no awkward truth whatever if you
then continue
let's continue in the last one yeah okay
whatever well
if you then create a new movie and you
do exactly the same thing
essentially
it's a bit of a
um what's the word cough out oh I think
I think it's just Multiverse in general
is a cop-out
it's a I really like Multiverse stories
my favorite some of my favorite episodes
from Stargate were the Multiverse ones
were the quantum mirror
um
you know when I have to go back is it
quantum error I think it is called one
number where they go
and the grow older like destroying
another Earth and then they save like
uh alternate Sam alternate
um what was his name Kowalski
but they're interesting episodes but
it's something that's been done a lot in
Stargate I don't think it needs to be a
movie I don't think that's a good
premise for a movie
yeah because it's just taking a very
easy way out from from something that's
already happened in the in the show
it's basically the equivalent of we have
this truck in in our driveway how do we
get rid of it without moving it oh we
have zap nicotels that can literally
disintegrate it
because you have something in Canon and
it's the easiest way to get rid of it
rather than let's do something
interesting to get rid of it yeah
I know I agree with you
and that's the problem is that we've got
too much technology maybe that a lot of
these problems can be solved too quickly
and I think that's one of the problems
whoever ends up
coming into this is gonna have whereas
maybe that's why I'm Multiverse I think
the argument though is that
we've all they've already implied that
Stargate is a Multiverse franchise
it is it is it has the Multiverse in it
um but they don't really interact the
same way a Multiverse does
they're very self-contained episodes
they're very self like they meet each
other once but they'll never meet each
other again
whereas in the Multiverse
um
the characters will interact at least
semi-regularly
um
yeah I know what you mean
I'd have I think having
a Multiverse of Stargate characters
where they interact semi-regularly
is a terrible idea
because they could in theory as soon as
any problem crops crops up use the
quantum mirror look into it and then go
let's find a universe where they've
already solved this problem and ask them
and then like what what's wrong with you
yeah
yeah it does again it
mindfulness is it's been it's been done
before yeah
um where they've gone had to go into I
mean this is basically
those episodes where they go into the
Multiverse at the end of was it season
one or season two
um well anyway the the goal would have
attacked and defeated the SGC in the
Multiverse
um maybe season one
we're Daniel fans the mirror yeah the
problem we've got is we don't actually
know who which pitch one
this pitch could have won
we think it's going to be Warner
Brothers that are going to be making
this
so that really does put Heyday films and
Bad Robot very firmly in the spotlight
Bad Robot obviously has an exclusivity
deal with Warner Brothers and Heyday
films as well the Harry Potters are all
done with Warner Brothers so
one of these pitches you could have won
this
um
Heyday films are arguing that this
should be a hard reboot and Bad Robot
are arguing this Multiverse nonsense and
Multiverse is popular at the moment
yeah Andrew Chandler and chat you said
are people not getting fed up with
Multiverse by now in sci-fi in general
yeah I am
I I I'm I'm incredibly fed up with it no
it's lazy everything has a Multiverse
now The Flash had the CW verse and every
single character even though they
weren't on the same Earth ended up
interacting with each other that was
really annoying
um Marvel obviously now has their whole
uh Multiverse the DC movies are now
doing a Multiverse and it's it's a cheap
way of just bringing in like you can try
a character like you can try a concept
out as a standalone and then just like
oh now they're in the main thing because
Multiverse
I don't like it I mean to play devil's
advocate here
yeah
I don't like it let's actually try and a
Multiverse slash a time travel based
story would be a very very good way for
them to essentially not start new but to
have to start without all of the the the
the the hanging threads that come from
the previous three seasons because they
can explain it away by saying this
happened in the movie
and when we defeated them when we
changed the timeline or we went to this
alternate reality or whatever this
changed
it's an easy it's an easy way of doing
it and it might be
an option for the I mean the way the way
I'm the way I'm envisioning it
which in my head is
powerful to watch
is they have
a story where they have to I don't know
this reality is dying or a reality is
dying
um and essentially they they end up
being stuck in another reality
where everything is the same but a
little bit different
so maybe they don't have all the
technology that we we have now maybe we
didn't we never got the answer card call
maybe we didn't actually go to Atlantis
maybe the crew of the destiny aren't
stuck anymore
and they could they could actually have
a series based in this Ultimate Reality
but the characters are from this one so
it's still Canon
okay
I don't know this is just off of my head
kind of thinking but right Aaron eat
your dinner and then come back
um I'm sorry it's bothering me
um I love Aaron he's got he's brilliant
but I'm doing it
um yeah I know what you mean lots of
little differences it it opens up lots
of different story ideas I think to um
explore and then
um
you know
it's just it's it's just going to back
to that argument
it's been done
yeah I don't know when they're over just
said sounds like a bit too much like the
uh the open style strike movie and I
fully agree it's not
it's not a great
idea
but
if I was to make the best of a bad
situation
I don't know
maybe I'll do something like that but
has had conversations with Amazon
potentially about being involved in this
so
um at Penguin Park isn't Mark fergus's
request apparently
um so
I I keep arguing
the a lot of sci-fi tries to be too
clever
sometimes and then actually these things
are just simpler than this
that they don't need
to be so overly complicated
um but what they're going to try to do
here is they're going to try and shoe
horn in
okay Russell yep because he's a big film
star and they want a film star and
they're going to try to then shoe horn
in
sg1 because they know the fans will go
nuts and that will be where they start
the premise
we need something with Kurt Russell
Richard Dean Anderson and a few other
stars from sg1 and you need to respect
all of the Canon across the board
and then the writers they're going to go
in ah crap how do I do that
and that's when we then get
crap episodes of Stargate Star Trek
starting when they try to do this and
they try to force
something from the beginning rather than
just trying to do something good
Aaron give us a wave when you've
finished your dinner and you want to
come back in
it's immediately what happened yeah I
was actually on my last bite when you
booted me so it's just a problem
I get it that's distracting I wasn't
thinking I was I was just hungry
um
all right so
at its most basic level if you're
dealing with sci-fi you're dealing with
astrophysics which means you're dealing
with alternate Dimension Theory they
just all go together
um on a basic level now
when it comes to creating a Sci-Fi show
or TV series obviously your first
decision is going to be How Deeply or if
at all do I want to dive into that mess
and if I do choose to dive into that
mess
how am I going to do it well enough to
where people won't be like um all right
I've already seen this crap on like
three other IPS and I'm tired of it
ah so
on the face of it I'm not I don't have
too big of a problem with the idea but
uh with what's been coming out lately
I.E The Flash flopping multiversal movie
um all of Marvel's phase four and the
first little bit of phase five has all
been well 95 percent of it's been mid to
crap
um so if they do take that pitch I think
in the current climate that would be an
absolutely horrific idea
um now if
now if the flash was blowing up
um it's phase four for Marvel hadn't
sucked for the most part basically if
people hadn't been given like garbage
Multiverse content for the last two
years
it wouldn't be as bad of an idea the
problem is is they're working against
history right now yeah
so yeah actually prefer if they did this
five or six years ago even three because
it's already in Canon
you know they're not they're not doing
something that this isn't like JJ Abrams
when he did that basically
thinking he's being clever
and created this split bottom line and
everyone is like going whoa whoa whoa
where'd this come from and it would
Stargate they'll go
we can do this because it is Canon we've
done it before
yeah I think the timing is probably the
worst part of the idea
like if they'd if they'd have been you
know on their horse and gotten this
pitch done
with like you know early 2020 after
after uh phase three of Marvel finished
when Infinity war and end game like when
that stuff was still very popular and
very cool and everyone was like
time to do it now is not the time
at all it's it's other franchises have
already killed multiversal aspects at
least probably for a good year or two at
this point so
see I would prefer I think it's more of
a timing issue than anything and then
after that sorry after that
oh he's gone
I didn't kick him that time that wasn't
me you didn't he's actually gone I don't
know I would prefer rather than a
Multiverse story a
I think a time travel movie
something that involves time travel
because
this is just me thinking off top of my
head
it could appease
[Music]
I
was just suddenly thinking
oh God
there we go I just certainly thinking
maybe if I used my phone it wouldn't lag
oon about closing this before I didn't
need to open it
um anyway but yeah I I'm thinking a a
time travel Timeless joint could be
slightly better because it would appease
all of the people who want to shoehorn
in Kurt Russell because you can
literally do a Tran travel movie that
goes back to the original movie
or at least ties in up to around that
time yeah
um and obviously you can have actual
Richard Dean Anderson you could have
Amanda Staffing you can have all of the
the new people I say new people the
people that we actually care about
yeah as well
and then you can use that as a vehicle
to change some things that you maybe
want to change for the future to make
the story makes sense in the future like
uh technology wise I guess like make it
so
I don't know something that they chose
to do in the past has a ripple effect in
the future and therefore that thing is
no longer happened they still have the
knowledge of it but they don't have the
physical
like locations of like certain planets
maybe they don't have maybe they didn't
actually go to Atlantis so they don't
they don't have
like The Wraith never woke up or
something like that I mean I I I
wouldn't actually suggest that as an
actual thing because then you'd have to
like redo the entire story Atlantis
storyline but
I don't know the biggest one I can think
of is the Asgard core we never got it
the Asgard just
maybe we never
I don't know maybe we never became the
fifth race in their eyes and they never
gave it to us because of something that
happened in the past yeah we became
Godlike at the end we we were equal
power with the Asgard by the end which
is a big problem but Ron Mars got a big
point and I think it's really important
and it's a big problem with Star Trek at
the moment that they keep going
backwards
instead of going forwards yeah and this
is what we you know this is I think
sci-fi fans are sick of it
um we want to go forwards we don't want
to go backwards all the damn time I want
to make it known I don't want either one
of those scenarios I don't want a
Multiverse story I don't really want a
time travel story because I want I want
it to continue from where I left off I
don't mind but
I don't mind the time travel movie
you're in Multiverse movie or something
like that I just don't want it to start
with that and because what they're gonna
do I do not want a JJ Abrams Star Trek
thing that you go well it's Star Trek
but it isn't it's not me
um
so are they going to have an SG panel
sdcc right there has been some Uncle so
sorry I'm scratching my nose slowly
um
well there is
um Marvel currently
at San Diego Comic-Con
um Warner Brothers are not going to be
um who else was it Universal is not
going to be at standard Comic-Con and
Netflix is not going to San Diego
Comic-Con
yeah well the main reason why Warner
Brothers is going to be this because
they've got no major sci-fi projects to
talk about
um so um basically for
um
Max so I had to think about what it's
called now and what's it called this
week uh Max
next week and then it's going to be M
and then yeah and then it's going to be
X
I love this channel um
so at the moment sorry Amazon can pretty
much go in and a couple of people
basically have told us
including one person is quite close to
it that
Amazon are going in in force and that
was the word they used in force oh it is
very possible that we will have a
Stargate panel seeing that they've gone
to every other
thing in the last you know and every
other Comic-Con in the last 12 months
I think if they can they'll go
yeah you know that's that's that's the
way it'll be so um the short answer is
right now we don't know
the long answer is
um
very possibly
it's going to come down to seg
it really could but right we were we
thought the directors might not ratify
that deal
they came up with there was a lot of
rumors and there was a lot but it sounds
like we even said in the video when I
talked about this though that is it a
loud minority
or is it
um or is it showing us that they might
not ratify this now actually they
ratified it by 87 oh that's official now
because I knew the vote ended yesterday
yeah so it's been ratified they've
agreed it that again takes the legs out
from under anything else so
um at least till SEC does whatever it is
they're gonna do well stag have voted
that if they don't get a deal by the end
of the month they will strike that's
what they've probably voted and it was a
massive like 97 all right so we got a
week on that one then another month next
Friday
I've because of the people I speak to
I've basically been told that a lot of
the studios went nuts Wednesday and
started folding Road agents and things
just started to try to get stuff planned
to restart
and there was basically the guy I spoke
to said the phones haven't stopped
ringing basically
I think that's probably because they got
whiff
that then just before it was officially
announced that the directors were going
to ratify
and they're they're taking that this is
just me two and two you know plus four
sort of thing
um reading between the lines that they
think because of that that they're gonna
get a deal
with the writers and the because the the
basic idea is that it wants one of these
people agree then that gives a blueprint
for everybody else
and all of a sudden the writer's Guild
lose his face if they start demanding
things that the directors have agreed to
so they're still like uh come on the
directors agreed why can't you something
so all of a sudden I think they lose a
lot of the window their sales goes
sagafra is basically the same problem
you know
um yeah I like Adam's there so whatever
I did you know we're going to watch it
yeah we will
the question is whether or not we're
going to watch it the question is is
whether we're gonna like it and then
praise it on YouTube or crap on it on
YouTube that's the question
I've always I'm always honest on this
channel it's one of the things I pride
myself I I try not to be negative I try
not to be positive I just try to be
honest about what I think
so if it's crap
you'll see me cry
I mean live on a live stream
if I come out of the cinema and this
movie is [__]
you will see a grown man cry
when it comes out to the cinema we
should go together
yeah okay let's do that how far apart do
you guys live
just out here
okay about an hour I mean I'd love to go
with you but I don't have a passport so
okay
no that's because you eat on live
streams they won't let you have a
passport yeah probably
we saw him don't give him one
um we don't actually don't like the
country no I would go let him out the
country
if they knew they would not only let me
out they would probably Usher me out
right to fix my internet issues I will
get an ethernet cable
Matthew has already explained to me that
I've been naughty and I'm I'm just there
going I don't know how to get it past my
front door but
yes
a lot of cat six in a drill
no yeah drill just get a flat cable a
flat cable
and my other option is to come through
the floor
that's the one I would go with
personally rather than having a cable up
and down doorways and up and down
doorways around it's that's just me
though even if it even even if it is oh
you go under it yeah I have to go around
downstairs I can't go under and there's
no you take the tiles up and then you
pull it under then you put the tiles
down
you come and do it the glue down
like
Jay does not look like the type that
enjoys chiseling grout
um I'm hard enough I had to pry it you
know that metal strip on your door
um I had to pry that off to put it under
just put it back down that was glued I
mean it's fine you underestimate my
laziness I'm just gonna get my dad to
come do it well I mean on top of that a
metal strip will Flex uh if he tries
that with tile they're just gonna
shatter
but anyway let's have enough of my
internet issues it keeps coming it's
fine now look look it's got good look
um
so we'll just recap so this is
everything we know right about the
pictures that we had Eric Kripke pitched
he's pitched a TV series he pitched it
very much along the lines of the
um plot that he had and he basically
um
we're quite happy with that penguin in a
Parker did the SG-1 Revival and this is
what they've pitched as that is going to
be very much around the formula of sg1
Heyday films were very keen to do a hard
reboot they seem to think a hard reboot
was the way to go
and Bad Robot are morons that's
basically everything we know yeah
um about this
[Music]
is this the same [__] key that created
the Supernatural on the CW yes yes okay
and what was his pitch again I'm sorry
Last Summer
and around
um August and then again in November
they did no what was it
um it very much did just a
I haven't really got a lot of details oh
yeah but it was going to be a
continuation and it was going to be
um
along the lines of roughly again along
the lines of like an sg1 Revival sort of
thing but it was a different story but
okay well I mean I'm down for well
number one I'm down for a Revival
continuation above any other option
um and number two I personally am a big
Supernatural fan so I started the
Winchester
I mean kinda it could end up being that
I don't I think kripke's got a little
more imagination but I personally am a
big Supernatural fan so I'd be down with
him or uh Mark Fergus because they both
kind of from
what I'm hearing you say they both
basically have kind of the same idea
and obviously with fergus's history with
the expanse and my own personal
experience with uh Kripke and
Supernatural
I would
I would say that those are the top two
personal choices of how I hope they
would go
with things
yeah that's basically where we're and we
we think they because again
that I think I will try to find out a
bit more about what Kripke actually
pitched um I need to have a longer
conversation with the with the source
but
um
it's interesting that they apparently
they came in they stuck to the brief and
we know what the brief was we knew the
brief that it was to stick to the Bible
that um Mark Fergus had created it has
to be a continuation and it has to stick
with at least I was told about 80 of
Canon they're not allowed to mess with
any more than about 20 they can change
um
I'd prefer turn but that ain't bad
well the main thing for me is don't
change the look of things yes wines me
for Star Trek so much oh we'll just
change the look and then we're just like
[Music]
um
the goal will still need to be the gold
we've already changed them once they're
already different to the movie but then
they've had 10 years setting up what the
gold where they start if they'd have a
grow old and his eyes cat are on fire
rather than glowing
all right
yeah I don't I don't want that because
that's changing something that is very
well established I mean they did change
stuff in sg1 anyway they changed that
nicotyle like they just stopped using
the disintegrate thing
they used it once or twice didn't they
when
um I mean whatever the evidence of what
they've been up to in 1916.
yeah yeah but um no I I yeah anyway
Multiverse or Madness
Madness it is madness
yes a great movie if you like Remy
I hated that movie
are you not a Remy fan because that I am
at summering the fan a lot of the time
that film was maybe too much but it was
the same problem with Marvel that they
didn't spend enough on the special
effects and they were distracting at
times and it's it went on a bit I did
love the um the fight scene between
Scarlet witch and the alternate defense
um
Illuminati Illuminati sort of thing yeah
I thought that was pretty cool yeah that
was good yeah but yeah I I just want to
say anything why not
I don't want to put team together
the boys is brilliant because there's
like eight different production
companies all working together why
couldn't Kripke and Fergus work together
oh they could I well I personally don't
see a reason why they couldn't I mean
call me practical but the more Minds you
have on a project that
both already or that all already agree
that the original material is worthy of
the utmost respect which is a big issue
in lucasfilm right now but I will not
digress further than that
um
that would be for me ideal like even in
even if they were to say
they got Fergus and whoever wants to do
the like somehow they managed to get
Ferguson Bad Robot together
if for no other reason than for Fergus
to keep bad robots ideas in check and
marching at least mostly along the line
with Canon that's even that's even a
scenario I would be okay with as long as
penguin and aparco were the ones that
had the um final say on what Israel is
not in the movie and could keep a leash
on a Bad Robot
but over overall I'd rather I would I
would love to see Kripke in uh penguin
in a parka combine their ideas I think
that would be pretty cool
I just think Mark Fergus I'm just hoping
they really haven't tried to be clever
with this or that politics hasn't got in
the way
because if they decide to go in Warner
Brothers Warner Brothers might basically
say
you're not working with them we're more
than willing to have this deal but
you've got to work with either Heyday
films or Bad Robot and we would actually
love you to work with Bad Robot because
we've got this bloody exclusivity deal
we can't get out of
um I mean if Amazon chooses to work with
Warner Brothers after the flash that's
just freaking dumb and we're probably
screwed anyway yeah well they've got
lots of problems they've got lots of
projects already in the works of Warner
Brothers
um well I mean yeah I'm talking about
specifically Stargate though I don't
care what else they do with them I mean
that was the old DC we have to remember
that that the The Flash had all the same
problems as old DC we're not going to be
getting that hopefully this is the end
of the snide of this and we've got one
more movie to come in and then that
would be it hopefully we got Blue Beetle
and Aquaman 2. now crap like if you've
got my Blue Beetle because nobody cares
yeah
supposedly blue beetles are going to be
the actual first gun DTU character
introduced
well yeah but apparently the flash was
good
according I mean the flash was
the Flash's problem was less the quality
of the movie itself but the CGI was just
whack Beyond description
um those babies looked like it looked
like the same people did the babies that
did um the Rocks scorpion hybrid Critter
at the end of The Mummy Returns that's
how bad that was
um and the overhype the the support
people zazzloff getting Tom Cruise and
other big celebrities call it like this
spectacular movie and they spent the
last year and a half doing it and then
it didn't live up
what the hell do you expect to happen at
that point
so I would say I still don't trust
Warner Brothers just because of the
they had the mentality that they
couldn't make force that to work and it
didn't
so what's to stop them from getting that
same moronic mentality when it comes to
our Stargate
yeah and that's the problem is I I do
think there will be business involved in
this and Amazon at the end of the day or
a business and that's how they think we
know that that's one of the reasons why
we're getting a movie in that series
because they've taken a business
decision
they've already got the budget they've
got this plan so they've gone oh why
don't we use some of that to make a
Stargate movie instead of what is right
for the franchise they've
done what is easy for the business model
yeah but I mean now that's I think
that's the problem with all RPS all our
IP currently is
they're all sliding into that trap at
this point like it's it's all becoming a
very very corporate at this point which
I mean I can even see a scenario where
like say Amazon does everything
completely right all us current Gators
are happy
and they also managed to bring in a
whole new audience and everything's
slapping
eventually
the corporate stuff is gonna the the
execs are gonna get in there and they're
gonna be like well we're a publicly
traded company
and you know we need to do this this and
this to maximize profits and they aren't
going to care for her it's the franchise
and I I I
regardless regard even if Amazon starts
off gangbusters with this and everyone
loves it us and normies and newbies
included there will come a point in time
probably within three to five years
where the where the corporate BS is
going to start leaking in and we're
going to be like
yeah
that's just how I feel about it
yeah just kind of showing the Rhymes
that way we can have Stargate Anatomy
that's very good Dave it's very good all
right then guys thank you so much for
for jumping in like I say I had to share
that with you um I will try to find out
more I need to find out is who actually
won
yeah nobody seems to know
so with to me we're trying to keep it
very very quiet I mean while I would
love to know more details of kripke's
pitch if he's not the one they picked it
kind of doesn't matter so I I would I
agree with you I think which pitch was
accepted as the first priority and then
if it happens to be someone who's pitch
we know less about than others then we
can worry about delving into those
details
well the important thing is as well that
we have to remember that Amazon have
rejected some of these pictures that we
know about because they've said it's too
much like a hard reboot so that's
important but anyway here we go Matt's
got to go have his dinner I've got to go
and do I've got to go and fix my
internet I'm gonna have to go order an
ethernet cable
I'm gonna have to go through the floor
though
yeah I got errands I gotta run this
afternoon too well for me it's afternoon
you guys enjoy your evening we will have
a lovely evening thank you very much
everybody thanks for joining us in the
comments as always the guys that have
contributed with um that's with chats um
super chats really really appreciate it
and Matt I know you were a bit rushed
today so thank you so much and guys Matt
is currently editing a video
um that I think a few of you in the chat
will be very happy about
um but we have got if it works if it
works we'll get it to work one way or
another
um but at the moment health and safety
guy is retiring
um
that's some of your best stuff bro
nobody wants it
so doing it I enjoy doing it it's fun
all right well Pat you hear that we need
to share the health and safety guy out
because that that's Prime stuff at least
in my opinion get to work Chad yeah I
enjoy doing it but um there we go and we
will be back very very soon for another
video so uh we will not be live tomorrow
guys I'm so sorry about that but anyway
say bye everybody
bye bye everybody
thanks guys foreign
[Music]
foreign